The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's start.
So let's review what
we've been trying
to do in the past few lectures.
It's to understand a typical
situation involving something
like a gas, which,
let's say, initially
is in one half of the container.
And then expands until it
occupies the entire container,
going from one equilibrium state
to another equilibrium state.
Question is, how
to describe this
from the perspective of
microscopic degrees of freedom,
getting the idea
that eventually you
will come to some
form of equilibrium.
And actually, more seriously,
quantifying the process
and timescales by which the
gas comes to equilibrium.
So the first stage was to
say that we will describe
the process by looking at
the density, which describes
the number of representative
examples of the system, whose
collections of
coordinates and momenta
occupy a particular point in
the 6N-dimensional phase space.
So basically, this is a function
that depends on 6N coordinates.
And of course, it changes
as a function of time.
And we saw that,
basically, if we
were to look at how
this set of points
were streaming in
phase space, and this
can be mathematically
represented
by looking at the
direct time dependence
and the implicit time
dependence of all
of the coordinates captured
through the Poisson bracket.
And the answer was that
it is a characteristic
of the type of Hamiltonian
evolution equations,
that the flow is such that
the phase space does not
change volume.
And hence, this quantity is 0.
We said, OK, all
of that is fine.
But what does that tell me
about how this gas is expanding?
So for that, we
said that we need
to look at descriptions that
are more appropriate to thinking
about the volume and
density of a gas expanding.
And we really want
to capture that
through the
one-particle density.
But along the way, we
introduced s particle densities,
normalized up to something,
to correspond to, essentially,
integrating over all
of the coordinates
that we're not interested in.
Say coordinates pertaining
to numbers s plus 1 to N,
corresponding
6N-dimensional phase
space and the entire [INAUDIBLE]
of this density or probability.
Then the next stage was to
be more specific about what
governs the evolution of
these gas particles, i.e.,
what is the Hamiltonian.
And we said, let's focus on
an N particle Hamiltonian that
is composed, by
necessity certainly,
of one-body terms that
is the kinetic energy
and the potential energy, the
latter describing the box,
for example.
And we added a
two-particle interaction.
qi minus qj, which, for
the sake of simplicity,
let's imagine is
spherically symmetric--
only depends on the relative
position of these particles.
Then we say that if I
look at the evolution
of this s particle
density, I start
by writing an equation
that kind of looks
like the full
Liouville equation.
There is a Hamiltonian that
describes this set of particles
interacting among themselves,
just replacing n by s.
And so if these were the only
particles in the universe,
this is what I would get.
Except that we know that
there are other particles.
And since we have two-body
collisions possible,
any one of the particles in the
set that I'm describing here,
composed of s particles,
can potentially
collide with a
particle from this set
that I don't want to include.
And that will change the
volume of phase space.
This incompressibility
condition was valid
only if the entire thing of
the Hamiltonian was considered.
Here, I'm only looking
at the partial subset.
And so then what
did I have here?
I had the force exerted
from particle s plus 1
on particle n changing the
momentum of the particle n.
But the likelihood
that this happens
depends on finding the
other particle also.
So I had this dependence on
the density that was s plus 1.
So this was the BBGKY hierarchy.
Then we said, let's take a
look at the typical value
of the terms that we
have in this equation.
And for s that is larger
than 2, this Hamiltonian
that pertains to
s particles will
have a collision term
among the particles.
And that collision term will
give you some typical inverse
timescale here, which is
related to the collision time.
Whereas on the right-hand
side, for this collision
to take place, you have
to find another particle
to interact with in the
range of interactions
that we indicated by d.
And for density n,
this was smaller
by a factor of nd
cubed for dilute gases.
Therefore, the left-hand
side is much larger
than the right-hand side.
And within particular
approximation,
we said that we are going
to approximately set
this right-hand side to 0.
OK?
Except that we couldn't
do this for the equation
that pertained to s equals to
1, because for s equals to 1,
I did not have the
analog of this term.
If I were to write the precise
form of this Poisson bracket,
I had the partial
derivative with respect
to time, the momentum
divided by mass,
which is the velocity driving
the change in coordinate.
And the force that comes
from the external potential,
let's call it f1, we
arrive in the change
in momentum of the one-particle
density, which is a function--
let's write it explicitly--
of p1, q1, and t.
And on the other side,
I had the possibility
to have a term such
as this that describes
a collision with
a second particle.
I have to look at all
possible second particles
that I can collide with.
They could come with
all variety of momenta,
which we will indicate p2.
They can be all over the place.
So I have integrations
over space.
And then I have
a bunch of terms.
So for this, we said, let's
take a slightly better look
at the kind of collisions
that are implicitly described
via the term that we
would have here as f2.
And since the right-hand side
of f2 we set to 0, essentially,
f2 really describes
the Newtonian evolution
of two particles coming
together and having a collision.
And this collision,
I can-- really,
the way that I
have it over there
is in what I would
call a lab frame.
And the perspective
that we should have
is that in this frame,
I have a particle that
is coming with
momentum, let's say,
p1, which is the one
that I have specified
on the left-hand
side of the equation.
That's the density
that I'm following
in the channel
represented by p1.
But then along comes a
particle with momentum p2.
And there is some
place where they
hit each other, after which
this one goes off with p1 prime.
Actually, let me call
it p1 double prime.
And this one goes off
with p2 double prime.
Now, we will find it
useful to also look
at the same thing in the
center of mass frame.
Now, in the center of
mass frame-- oops--
my particle p1 is coming
with a momentum that
is shifted by the p
of center of mass,
which is really
p1 plus p2 over 2.
So this is p1 minus p2 over 2.
And my particle number two
comes with p2 minus center
of mass, which is
p2 minus p1 over 2.
So they're minus each other.
So in the center
of mass frame, they
are basically coming to each
other along the same line.
So we could define one of
the axes of coordinates
as the distance along
which they are approaching.
And let's say we put
the center of mass
at the origin,
which means that I
have two more
directions to work with.
So essentially, the coordinates
of this second particle
can be described
through a vector b,
which we call the
impact parameter.
And really, what
happens to the collision
is classically determined by
how close they approach together
to make that.
To quantify that, we really
need this impact vector.
So b equals to 0, they are
coming at each other head on.
For a different b, they
are coming at some angle.
So really, I need
to put here a d2b.
Now, once I have specified the
form of the interaction that
is taking place when the
two things come together,
then the process is
completely deterministic.
Particle number one will come.
And after the location at
which you have the interaction,
will go off with p1 double
prime minus center of mass.
And particle number
two will come and get
deflected to p2 prime minus--
or double prime minus p
center of mass.
OK?
And again, it is important
to note that this parameter
A is irrelevant to the
collision, in that once I have
stated that before
collision, I have a momentum,
say, p1 and p2.
And this impact
parameter b is specified,
then p1 double prime
is known completely
as a function of p1, p2, and b.
And p2 double prime
is known completely
as a function of p1, p2, and b.
And everything in that
sense is well-defined.
So really, this parameter
A is not relevant.
And it's really the
B that is important.
But ultimately, we also need
to get these other terms,
something that has the
appropriate dimensions
of inverse time.
And if I have a density
of particles coming
hitting a target, how
frequently they hit
depends on the product
of the density as well
as the velocity.
So really, I have to
add here a term that
is related to the velocity
with which these things are
approaching each other.
And so I can write it either
as v2 minus v1, or p2 minus 1
over m.
So that's the other thing
that I have to look at.
And then, essentially,
what we saw
last time is that the
rest of the story-- if you
sort of think of these
as billiard balls,
so that the collision is
instantaneous and takes place
at a well-specified
point, instantaneously,
at some location, you're
going with some momentum,
and then turn and go
with some other momentum.
So the channel that was
carrying in momentum p1, which
is the one that we are
interested in, suddenly
gets depleted by an
amount that is related
to the probability of having
simultaneously particles
of momenta p1 and p2.
And the locations that I
have to specify here-- well,
again, I'm really
following this channel.
And in this channel,
I have specified q1.
And suddenly, I see that
at the moment of collision,
the momentum changes, if you are
thinking about billiard balls.
So really, it is
at that location
that I'm interested
for particle one.
For particle two, I'm
interested at something
that is, let's say, q1
plus, because it depends
on the location of particle
two shifted from particle one
by an amount that is
related by b and whatever
this amount slightly
of A is that is related
to the size of
your billiard ball.
OK?
Now, we said that there is a
corresponding addition, which
comes from the fact that it
is possible suddenly to not
have a particle moving
along, say, this direction.
And the collision of
these two particles
created something
along that direction.
So the same way
that probabilities
can be subtracted
amongst some channels,
they can be added to
channels, because collision
of two particles
created something.
And so I will indicate
that by p1 prime, p2 prime,
again, coordinates in
t, something like this.
So basically, I try to be a
little bit more careful here,
not calling these
outgoing channels p prime,
but p double prime.
Because really, if
I were to invert
p1 double prime and
p2 double prime,
I will generate things
that are going backward.
So there's a couple of
sign issues involved.
But essentially, there
is a similar function
that relates p1
prime and p2 prime.
It is, basically, you
have to search out
momenta whose outcome
will create particles
in the channels
prescribed by p1 and p2.
So as we said, up
to here, we have
done a variety of
approximations.
They're kind of
physically reasonable.
There is some difficulty
here in specifying
if I want to be very accurate
where the locations of q1
and q2 are within
this interaction size
d that I am looking at.
And if I don't think about
billiard balls, where
the interactions are not
quite instantaneous where
you change momenta, but
particles that are deformable,
there is also certainly
a certain amount of time
where the potential is acting.
And so exactly what time
you are looking at here
is also not appropriate--
is not completely, no.
But if you sort of make all
of those things precise,
then my statement is
that this equation still
respects the reversibility
of the equations of motions
that we had initially.
But at this stage, we
say, well, what can
I do with this equation?
I really want to
solve an equation that
involves f of p1, q1, and t.
So the best that
I can do is, first
of all, simplify all
of the arguments here
to be more or less
at the same location.
I don't want to think about
one particle being shifted
by an amount that is related
by b plus something that
is related to the interaction
potential size, et cetera.
Let's sort of change our focus,
so that our picture size,
essentially, is
something that is
of the order of the
size of the interaction.
And also, our
resolution in time is
shifted, so that we don't
really ask about moments of time
slightly before and
after collision,
where the particle, let's say,
could be deformed or whatever.
So having done that, we
make these approximations
that, essentially,
all of these f2's,
we are going to replace
as a product of f1's
evaluated all at
the same location--
the location that
is specified here,
as well as the same time, the
time that is specified there.
So this becomes-- OK?
So essentially, the
result of the collisions
is described on the left-hand
side of our equation
by a term that integrates over
all momenta and overall impact
parameters of a bracket,
which is a product of two
one-particle densities.
And just to simplify
notation, I will call this
the collision term that
involves two factors of f1.
So that's just a
shorthand for that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is that
process equivalent
of a similar
molecule [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That, if you
want to give it a name, yes.
It's called the assumption
of molecular chaos.
And physically, it
is the assumption
that the probability to
find the two particles
is the product of
one-particle probabilities.
And again, we say
that you have to worry
about the accuracy
of that if you
want to focus on sizes that are
smaller than the interaction
parameter size.
But we change that as
part of our resolution.
So we don't worry
about that aspect.
AUDIENCE: So molecular
chaos doesn't
include eliminating this space?
It's a separate thing.
PROFESSOR: I've only seen the
word "molecular chaos" applied
in this context.
I think you are
asking whether or not
if q1 and q2 are different.
I can replace that and
call that molecular chaos.
I would say that that's
actually a correct statement.
It's not an assumption.
Basically, when
the two particles
are away from each other
to a good approximation,
they don't really know
about-- well, actually,
what I am saying is if I
really want to sort of focus
on time dependence, maybe
that is also an assumption.
Yes.
So they're really, if you
like, indeed, two parts.
It is the replacing of f2
with the product of two
f2's, and then evaluating
them at the same point.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But based on
your first line-- I mean,
you could break that assumption
of different distribution
functions have different events
that occur when they get close,
and the framework
still works, right?
It would just become-- when you
got down to the bottom line,
it would just become a much
larger equation, right?
PROFESSOR: I don't understand.
AUDIENCE: Like if you assume
different interactions.
PROFESSOR: The
interactions are here
in how p1 prime and p2
prime depend on p1 and p2.
AUDIENCE: Right.
What I'm suggesting
is if you change H
by keeping the top [INAUDIBLE].
That's a pretty simple
H. Would this framework
work for a more complicated H.
But then your bottom two lines
would become [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What
more can I do here?
How can I make
this more general?
Are you thinking
about adding it?
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
I'm not suggesting you
make it more general.
I'm suggesting you make
it more specific to break
that assumption of
molecular chaos.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So how should I modify
if I'm not saying--
AUDIENCE: I didn't
have something in mind.
I was just suggesting
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
where I have problem,
because it seems to me
that this is very general.
The only thing that I
left out is the body
interactions may be having to
do with this being spherically
symmetric.
But apart from that, this
is basically as general
as you can get with two bodies.
Now, the part that is
pertaining to three bodies,
again, you would basically--
not need to worry about as long
as nd cubed is less than 1.
So I don't quite know
what you have in mind.
AUDIENCE: I guess I was
thinking about three-
and four-body interactions.
But if you're covered against
that, then what I said,
it's not valid or relevant.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So certainly, three-body
and higher body interactions
would be important
if you're thinking
about writing a description
for a liquid, for example.
And then the story
becomes more complicated.
You can't really
make the truncations
that would give you
the Boltzmann equation.
You need to go by some
other set of approximations,
such as the Vlasov
equation, that you
will see in the problem set.
And the actual theory that
one can write down for liquids
is very complicated.
So it's-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can it get
more complicated yet
if, based on the same
framework, isn't this similar
to, like, the formulation
of the neutron transport
equation, where if you have,
in addition to scattering,
you have particles
that don't attract,
but you have fission events
and you have inelastic center?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yes.
That's good.
AUDIENCE: And then your H would
change dramatically, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's right.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But my point is
that it's the same framework.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
So basically, you're right.
One assumption that I have here
is that the number of particles
is conserved.
We say that if the particles
can break or diffuse,
one has to generalize
this approximation.
And there would be an
appropriate generalization
of the Boltzmann equation
to cover those terms.
And I don't have a problem
set related to that,
but maybe you are suggesting
that I should provide one.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
That's a good point.
OK?
All right.
So we have made some
assumptions here.
And I guess my claim is
that this equation-- well,
what equation?
So basically, what
I'm going to do,
I call the right-hand
side of this equation
after this assumption
of molecular chaos, CFF.
For simplicity, let me call
this bunch of first derivatives
that act on f1 L
for Liouvillian.
It's kind of like a
Liouville operator.
So I have an equation that is
the bunch of first derivatives
acting on f1, which
is essentially
a linear partial differential
equation in six or seven
dimensions, depending on
how you count time-- is
equal to a non-linear integral
on the right-hand side.
OK?
So this is the entity that
is the Boltzmann equation.
Now, the statement is that
this equation no longer
has time reversal symmetry.
And so if I were to solve this
equation for the one function
that I'm interested, after all,
the f1, which really tells me
how the particles stream from
the left-hand side of the box
to the right-hand
side of the box,
that equation is not reversible.
That is, the solution
to this equation
will indeed take
the density that
was on the left-hand
side of the box
and uniformly distribute it
on the two sides of the box.
And that will stay forever.
That's, of course, a consequence
of the various approximations
that we made here,
removing the reversibility.
OK?
And the statement to
show that mathematically
is that if there is a function--
and now, for simplicity,
since from now on, we don't
care about f2, f3, et cetera,
we are only caring about f1,
I'm going to drop the index one
and say that if there is a
density f, which is really
my f1, that satisfies
the Boltzmann-- that is,
I have a form such as this--
then there is a quantity H that
only depends on time that,
under the evolution that
is implicit in this Boltzmann
equation will always decrease,
where H is an integral
over the coordinates
and momenta that are in this
function f of p, q, and t.
And all I need to do is
to multiply by the log.
And then all of these
are vectors if I drop it
for saving time.
And we said that
once we recognize
that f, up to a
normalization, is
the same thing as the
one-particle probability--
and having previously
seen objects such as this
in probability
theory corresponding
to entropy information,
entropy of mixing,
you will not be surprised at
how this expression came about.
And I had told you that in
each one of the four sections,
we will introduce some quantity
that plays the role of entropy.
So this is the one that is
appropriate to our section
on kinetic theory.
So let's see how we go about--
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you introduced
the-- initialized the concept
of entropy of information
of the message that's
p log p, [INAUDIBLE] entropy.
And as far as I
understand, this concept
came up in, like, mid 20th
century at least, right?
PROFESSOR: I think
slightly later than that.
Of that order, yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And these are
Boltzmann equations?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And so this was, like,
100 years before, at least?
PROFESSOR: Not 100 years, but
maybe 60 years away, yeah.
50, 60.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'm just interested, what is
the motivation for picking
this form of functionality,
that it's integral of f log f
rather than integral
of something else?
PROFESSOR: OK.
I mean, there is another
place that you've seen it,
that has nothing to
do with information.
And that's mixing entropy.
If I have [? n ?] one
particles of one type
and two particles of
another type, et cetera,
and mixed them up, then
the mixing entropy,
you can relate to a
form such as this.
It is some ni log ni.
OK?
Fine.
It's just for
discrete variables,
it makes much more sense
than for the continuum.
But OK.
So let's see if this
is indeed the case.
So we say that dH
by dt is the-- I
have to take the time
derivative inside.
And as we discussed
before, the full derivative
becomes a partial derivative
inside the integral.
And I have either
acting on f and acting
on log f, which will
give me 1 over f,
canceling the f outside.
And this term corresponded
to the derivative
of the normalization,
which is fixed.
And then we had to replace
what we have for df by dt.
And for df by dt, we either
have the Poisson bracket
of the one-particle Hamiltonian
with f coming from the L
part of the equation, once
we get d by dt on one side.
And then the collision part
that depends on two f's.
And we have to
multiply this by f.
And again, let's remind you that
f really has argument-- oops,
log f-- that has argument p1.
I won't write q1 and t.
And the next thing that we
did at the end of last lecture
is that typically, when you have
integral of a Poisson bracket
by doing some combination
of integrations by part,
you can even eventually show
that this contribution is 0.
And really, the important
thing is the integration
against the collision term
of the Boltzmann equation.
So writing that explicitly,
what do we have?
We have that it is
integral d cubed.
Let's say q1.
Again, I don't
really need to keep
track of the index on
this dummy variable.
I have the integral over q1.
I have the two integral over p1.
Let's keep it so that it
doesn't confuse anybody.
Then I have the collision term.
Now, the collision term is
a bunch of integrals itself.
It involves integrals over p2,
integral over an impact vector
b, the relative velocity.
And then I had minus
f of p1, f of p2
for the loss in the channel
because of the collisions,
plus the addition to the channel
from the inverse collisions.
And this whole thing
has to be multiplied
by log f evaluated at p1.
OK?
So that's really the quantity
that we are interested.
And the quantity that we
are interested, we notice,
has some kind of a symmetry with
respect to indices one and two.
Something to do with prime
and un-prime coordinates.
But multiplied this bracket that
has all of these symmetries,
with this function that is only
evaluated for one of the four
coordinates for momenta
that are appearing here.
So our next set of tasks is to
somehow make this as symmetric
as possible.
So the first thing that we
do is we exchange indices one
and two, because really, these
are simply dummy integration
variables.
I can call the thing that I was
calling p1 p2, and vice versa.
And the integration then
becomes the integral over q.
Maybe that's why it's useful not
to have, for the q, any index,
because I don't care to
change the index for that.
d cubed p2, p1.
Doesn't really matter in
what order I write them.
d2b is a relative separation.
Again, it's an impact parameter.
I can call this v1 minus v2.
But since it's an
absolute value,
it doesn't matter really.
And so the only
thing that happens
is that I will have--
essentially, the product is
symmetric.
The only thing that
was separately f
of p1 before now
becomes f of p2.
And then what I can do is I
can say, OK, those are really
two forms of the same integral,
and I can average them,
and write the average, which is
1/2 the integral d cubed q, d
cubed p1, d cubed p2, d2 b,
relative velocity, minus f
of p1, f of p2, f of p1
prime, f of p2 prime.
And then I have a log of f
of p1 plus log of f of p2.
And I have divided through 1/2.
OK?
So what I will do is to
now write the next line.
And then we'll spend some
time discussing what happens.
So artificially, what will
happen looks like I essentially
move prime and un-prime things
the same way that I exchanged
one and two indices before.
I will exchange the superscripts
that are prime or non-prime.
And if I were to do that, I
will get an integral d cubed q,
d cubed, let's say, p1 prime,
d cubed p2 prime, d2b, v2 minus
v1 prime, minus
f of p1-- [SIGHS]
--prime, f or p2 prime,
plus f of p1, f of p2.
And then here, we
would have log of f
of p1 prime, log
of f of p2 prime.
OK?
So this is a statement
that just saying,
I moved the primes
and un-primes,
it's very easy to come
up with this answer.
What you have to think very
much about what that means.
Essentially, what I
had originally was
integration
invariables p1 and p2.
And p1 prime and p2 prime were
never integration variables.
So there was not
symmetry at the level
that I have written
between one and two, which
are integration
variables, and one prime
and two prime, which
are the quantities that,
through the collision operator,
are related to p1 and p2.
So essentially, p1
prime and p2 prime
are the kind of functions
that we have written here.
Here, I had p1 double
prime, p2 double prime.
But up to sort of inverting
some signs, et cetera,
this is the kind of functional
relationship that you have
between p primes and p's.
OK?
So now we have to worry
about a number of things.
The simplest one
is actually what
happened to this factor
here-- the relative velocity.
Now think back about
collisions that you
have in the center of mass.
In the center of
mass, two particles
come with velocities that
are opposite each other.
They bang onto each other,
go different direction.
The magnitude of the
velocities does not
change an inelastic
collision, which
is what we are looking at.
Right?
So after the collision, what
we have is that p2 prime minus
p1 prime is the same
thing as p1 and minus
p2 for elastic conditions.
So as far as this
factor is concerned,
I could very well replace
that with v1 minus v2
without the primes.
It really doesn't
make any difference.
Another thing that you
can convince yourself
is that from the perspective
of the picture that I drew,
there was some kind
of an impact vector B.
You say, well, what
happens if I look
at from the perspective of the
products of the interaction?
So the products
of the interaction
are going in a
different direction.
I would have to redraw
my coordinates that
would correspond to
A prime and B prime.
But what you can convince
yourself that essentially,
the impact parameter, as far
as these products is concerned,
is just a rotated version
of the original one
without changing its magnitude.
So you have also that
magnitude of b prime
is the same thing
as magnitude of b.
There's a rotation, but
the impact parameter
does not change.
If you like, that
is also related
to conservation of energy,
because if it wasn't so,
the potential energy
would be different
right after the collisions.
OK?
So I really was kind
of careless here.
I should have
written d2 b prime.
But I could have
written also d2b.
It didn't make any difference.
It's the same.
And then, of course, these
functions-- essentially,
you can see that you say, OK,
I start with, here, p1 and p2.
And these were
functions of p1 and p2.
And here, I have reversed this.
p1 prime and p2 prime are
the integration variables.
p1 and p2 are functions
of p1 prime and p2 prime
that, in principle, are
obtained by inverting
this set of equations.
Right?
But it really, again,
doesn't matter,
because once you have
specified what incoming p1, p2,
and b are, you know what the
outcome of the collision is.
So it's really
the same function.
Whether you are
inverting it, you
will, again, presume
the different location
of the arguments, but you will
have the same function that
would tell you what the
inverse relationship is.
So really, these
functional forms
are the same as the functional
forms that we had before.
And finally, I
claim that in order
to go through this
change of variable,
I have to also deal with the
Jacobian of the transformation.
But that we have the
d3p1d3p2 is the same thing
as d3p1 prime d3p2 prime.
And that, in some sense,
you can sort of also
think about what we were doing
before with the Liouville
equation maintaining the
volume of phase space.
So I have some volume of phase
space prior to the collision.
After the collision, I would
need to have the same volume.
There is, of course,
in the volumes
that we are considering for the
case of the Liouville operator,
in addition,
products of dq1, dq2.
But you can see that
all of those things
are really put into
the same volume when
we are considering
the collision.
So really, the only
thing that is left
is that the Liouvillian
preservation
of the volume of
phase space would
say that the Jacobian
here, you can also ignore.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So are you assuming
that this transformation
[INAUDIBLE] is [? an article, ?]
because it's [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So everything that we do
is within the framework
of a Hamiltonian
evolution equation.
OK?
So if you like,
these kinds of things
that I'm saying
here sometimes are
said to be consequence of
microscopic reversibility,
in that I'm sort of using,
in this panel over here,
things that are completely
Newtonian and microscopic.
The place that I use statistical
argument was over here.
OK?
So essentially,
having done that,
you can basically
also rename variables.
Things that I was calling
p1 prime I can call p1.
It's another renaming
of some variable.
And again, it really doesn't
matter which relative velocity
I write down.
They're all the same thing.
So what will happen
is that I will
get minus f or p1, f of p2, plus
f of p1 prime, f of p2 prime.
And the only thing that happened
is that the logs-- oops.
I should have maintained.
I don't know why--
where I made a mistake.
But I should ultimately have
come up with this answer.
So what I wanted
to do, and I really
have to maybe look
at it again, is
do one more step
of symmetrization.
The answer will come down to an
integral over p1 and p2, d2b,
at relative velocity.
We would have minus f of p1,
f of p2, plus f of p1 prime,
f of p2 prime.
So this is our
collision operator
that we have discussed
here-- the difference
between what comes in
and what comes out.
And from the first part here,
we should get log of f of p1,
plus log of f of p2,
which is the same thing
as the log of the product.
And if I had not made
errors, the subtraction
would have involved f of
p1 prime, f of p2 prime.
And the idea is that if you
think about the function
log of something as a
function of that something,
the log is a monotonic function.
So that if you were to
evaluate the log at two
different points,
the sign of the log
would grow in the same
way as the sign of the two
points, which means that here,
you have the difference of two
logs.
This is like log of
s1 minus log of s2.
And it is multiplied
with minus s1 minus s2.
So if s1 is greater
than s2, log s1
would be greater than log s2.
If s1 is less than s2, log
s1 would be less than log s2.
In either case,
what you would find
is that the product of the
two brackets is negative.
And this whole thing
has to be negative.
OK.
So the thing that confused
me-- and maybe we can go back
and look at is that probably,
what I was doing here
was a little bit too
impatient, because when
I changed variables,
p1 prime f of p2.
I removed the primes.
Log.
Reduced primes.
Actually, I had it here.
I don't know why I was worried.
Yeah.
So the signs are, I think,
right, that when I add them,
I would get the subtraction.
So in one case, I had the f's of
the p's with the negative sign.
After I did this change, they
appear with the positive sign.
So there is the sign difference
between the two of them.
OK?
So we have a
function, therefore,
that, just like entropy
throughout the process,
will increase.
This is like a negative entropy.
If I were to really solve
this set of equations,
starting with the f that
describes things that
are distributed in
this box, and then
allow it to expand
into the other box,
it will follow--
this solution will
follow some particular
trajectory that will ultimately
no longer change as
a function of time.
It will not go back and forth.
It will not have the
full reversibility
that these set of
equations does have.
Now, that's actually
not a bad thing.
It is true, indeed, that these
equations are reversible.
And there is a theorem that
if you wait sufficiently long,
this will go back into here.
But the time it take
for that to happen
grows something of the order of
the size of the system divided
these.
The time, up to
various pre-factors,
would grow exponentially
with the number of particles
that you have.
And remember that you
have of the order of 10
to the 23 particles.
So there is, indeed,
mathematically rigorously,
a recursion time if you really
had this box sitting in vacuum
and there was no influence on
the walls of the container.
After many, many, many,
many ages of the universe,
the gas would go back
for an instant of time
in the other box, and
then would go over there.
But that's something that really
is of no practical relevance
when we are thinking about
the gas and how it expands.
OK?
But now let's see, with
these approximations,
can we do better.
Can we figure out
exactly how long does it
take for the gas to go from
one side to the other side.
And what is the shape of the
streamlines and everything else
as this process is taking place?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
So if you like, we
want to think of this
in terms of information,
in terms of entropy.
It doesn't matter.
It is something that is
changing as a function of time.
And the timescale by
which that happens
has to do with the timescales
that we set up and imprinted
into this equation.
OK?
So the next step
that I have to answer
is, what is that time step?
And in particular, if I look
at this equation by itself,
I would say that it
has two timescales.
On the left-hand side,
you have this tau
that has to do with
the size of the box.
We said it's very long.
On the right-hand
side, it has the time
that I have to wait
for a collision
to occur, which is certainly
much shorter than this time,
for an ordinary gas.
And so we expect, therefore,
that the right-hand side
of this equation would determine
things much more rapidly
compared to the left-hand
side of the equation.
And we want to now
quantify that and make that
into something that
is relevant to things
that we know and understand
about a gas expand.
OK?
So let's sort of think about,
well, what would happen?
We said that this H,
as a function of time,
is going in one direction.
Presumably, after some time--
we don't know how long here,
and that's a good
question-- eventually,
hopefully, it will
reach an equilibrium,
like, the entropy
will cease to change.
And the question is,
what is this equilibrium?
So let's see if we can gain some
information about equilibrium.
So we said that dH
by dt presumably
has to be 0, because
if it is not 0,
then it can continue
to decrease.
You are not quite
where you want to be.
Now let's look at what is the
condition for dH by dt to be 0.
H is this integral that
I have to perform over
the entire phase space.
Now, each element of
that integral evaluated
at some particular
location in phase space
is by itself positive.
This argument that
we had before is not
about the entire integral.
It's valid about every little
piece of the integration
that I am making.
It has a particular sign.
So if the entire integral has to
be 0, every little piece of it
has to be individually 0.
So that means that
I would require
that log of f at
any q evaluated,
let's say, for p1 and p2
should be the same thing
as log of f evaluated
at p1 prime and p2.
This would be true for all q.
Right?
You look at this and
you say, well, what?
This seems kind of-- yes?
AUDIENCE: What about the
other one in parentheses,
beside the integral?
PROFESSOR: It is the same thing.
So this is s1 minus s2.
And the other is
log of s1 minus s2.
So I'm saying that the only time
it is 0 is s1 is equal to s2.
When s1 equals to s2,
both parentheses are 0.
Although, even if it wasn't,
it would have been sufficient
for one parentheses to be 0.
But this is necessary, because
the sign is determined by this.
OK?
Now, you look at this
and you say, well,
what the he-- what
does this mean?
How can I-- and the functions
p1 prime and p2 prime I
have to get by integrating
Newton's equations.
I have no idea how
complicated they are.
And you want me to
solve this equation.
Well, I tell you that
the answer to this
is actually very simple.
So let me write the
answer to it in stages.
Log of f of p and q.
So it's a function
of p and q that I'm
after that have to be
evaluated at p1, p2,
and then should be equal
to p1 prime and p2 prime
for any combination of p1,
p2, et cetera, that I choose.
Well, I say, OK, I will put
any function of q that I like.
And that will work, because
it's independent of p.
So I have minus
alpha, minus alpha
is the same as minus
alpha, minus alpha.
OK?
Then I claim that, OK, I
will put a minus gamma dot p.
Gamma could be dependent on q.
Dot p.
And I claim that that would
work, because that term would
give me gamma dot
p1 plus p2, gamma
dot p1 prime plus p2 prime.
What do I know for sure?
Momentum is conserved.
p1 plus p2 is the same thing
as p1 prime plus p2 prime.
It's just the
conservation of momentum.
I know that to be true for sure.
And finally, kinetic
energy is conserved.
Once I'm away from the location
where the interaction is taking
place, I can choose
any function of q
multiplied with p
squared over 2m.
And then on the
left-hand side, I
would have the sum of the
incoming kinetic energies.
On the right-hand
side, I would have
the sum of outgoing
kinetic energies.
So what have I done?
I have identified
quantities that
are conserved in the collision.
So basically, I
can keep going if I
have additional such things.
And so basically,
the key to this
is to identify
collision-conserved quantities.
And so momentum, energy,
the first one corresponds
to the number of particles.
These are quantities
that are conserved.
And so you know that
this form will work,
which means that I have a
candidate for equilibrium,
which is that f of p and q
should have a form that is
exponential of some function of
q that I don't-- at this stage,
could be quite arbitrary.
And some other function of
q times p squared minus 2m.
And let me absorb
this other gamma term.
I can certainly do so
by putting something
like pi of 1 squared over 2m.
OK?
And this certainly
is a form that
will set the right-hand
side of the H theorem to 0.
And furthermore, it
sets the right-hand side
of the Boltzmann equation
to 0, because, again,
for the Boltzmann
equation, all I
needed was that the
product of two f's
should be the same before
and after the collision.
And this is just the logs.
If I were to exponentiate that,
I have exactly what I need.
So basically, this also
sets the right-hand side
of the Boltzmann equation to 0.
And this is what I will
call a local equilibrium.
What do I mean by that?
Essentially, we can
see that right now, I
have no knowledge
about the relationship
between different
points in space,
because these alpha, beta, and
pi are completely arbitrary, as
far as my argumentation
so far is concerned.
So locally, at each point in q,
I can have a form such as this.
And this form, you
should remind you
it's something like a Boltzmann
weight of the kinetic energy,
but moving in some
particular direction.
And essentially,
what this captures
is that through relaxing
the right-hand side
of the Boltzmann
equation, we randomize
the magnitude of the momenta,
so that the magnitudes
of the kinetic energy are
kind of Boltzmann-distributed.
This is what this term does.
If I say that this term being
much larger than this term
is the more important one.
If I need neglect this,
then this is what happens.
I will very rapidly
reach a situation
in which the momenta
have been randomized
through the collisions.
Essentially, the
collisions, they
change the direction
of the momenta.
They preserve the
average of the momenta.
So there is some
sense of the momentum
of the incoming thing
that is left over still.
But there is some
relaxation that took place.
But clearly, this is not
the end of the story,
because this f that
I have written here--
let's say local equilibrium.
f local equilibrium does not
satisfy the Boltzmann equation.
Right?
It set the right-hand side of
the Boltzmann equation to 0.
But it doesn't set
the left-hand side.
The left-hand side completely
is unhappy with this.
For the left-hand
side to be 0, I
would require the Poisson
bracket of H1 and f to be 0.
After all, the
Liouvillian operator
had the Poisson
bracket of H1 and f.
And we have seen
functions that satisfy
this have to be of the form
f1 of H. And in our case,
my f1 is simply the kinetic
energy of one particle,
plus the potential
due to the box.
OK?
So you can see that the only way
that I can make this marriage
with this is to have a
global equilibrium, where
f for the global equilibrium
is proportional, let's say,
to exponential of minus beta
p squared over 2m plus U of q.
OK?
So I identify a piece that looks
like this p squared over 2m.
I have to make pi to be 0
in order to achieve this.
I have to make beta to
be independent of q.
I have to make alpha
of f marriage with beta
to give me the potential.
OK?
So essentially, what
happens is this.
I open this hole.
The gas starts to stream out.
And then the particles will
collide with each other.
The collision of particles
over some timescale that
is related to this
collision time
will randomize their momenta
so that locally, suddenly,
I have a solution such as this.
But then the left-hand side
of the Boltzmann equation
takes over.
And over a timescale
that is much longer,
it will then change
the parameters of this.
So basically, these
parameters should really
be thought of as functions of
time, whose evolution changes.
So initially, maybe
locally over here,
there is a stream velocity
that goes towards the right.
So I should have an
average at that time that
prefers to go to the right.
I wait sufficiently long.
Presumably, the whole
thing comes to equilibrium.
And that average goes
to 0 [INAUDIBLE].
So presumably, the
next thing that I
need to do in order to
answer the question,
how does this thing
come to equilibrium,
is to find out how the
left-hand side of the equation
manipulates these parameters
alpha, beta, and pi.
But that's not quite
consistent either.
Because I first assume that
the right-hand side is 0,
and then said, oh, that's
not a good solution.
Let's go and see what
the left-hand side does.
But then if the left-hand
side is changing things,
I can't be over here
where dH by dt is 0.
So I have not done
things consistently yet,
although I have clearly
captured the whole lot of what
I want to describe eventually.
OK?
So let's see how we can
do it systematically.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you [? write ?]
the condition for [INAUDIBLE],
[? did you ?] write
f1 of Hamiltonian.
And ends up
Hamiltonian [INAUDIBLE]
includes interaction terms.
PROFESSOR: It's the
one-particle Hamiltonian.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So by the time I got to the
equation for f1, I have H1.
H1 does not have a second
particle in it to collide with.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Then equilibrium
system's distribution
of particles in
container does not
depend on their interactions
after the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: In the story that
we are following here, yes, it
does not.
So this is an
approximation that actually
goes with the
approximations that we
made in neglecting some of the
higher order terms, with nd
cubed being much
less than 1, and not
looking at things at resolution
that is of the order of d.
And we would imagine that it
is only at the resolutions--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] neglected
[INAUDIBLE] atomized gas
conjoined onto the molecules.
Something like that.
PROFESSOR: That would require
a different description.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It would require [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So indeed.
Eventually, in the description
that we are going to get,
we are looking at
the distribution
that would be appropriate
to a dilute gas
and which interactions
are not seen.
OK?
All right.
So let's see how we
can do it better.
So clearly, the
key to the process
is that collisions that take
place frequently at timescale
tau x randomize a lot of things.
But they cannot randomize
quantities that are conserved
in collisions.
So those are the quantities
that we have to look at.
And again, these are
quantities that are conserved
in collision, as
opposed to quantities
that are conserved
according to H1.
Like, momentum is
conserved in the collision.
Clearly, momentum
was not conserved
in H1 because of
the size of the box
and did not appear in
the eventual solution.
OK.
Let's see what we get.
So we are going to make
a couple of definitions.
First, we define
a local density.
I say that I take my solution
to Boltzmann equation.
And now I don't know what it is.
But whatever it is,
I take the solution
to the Boltzmann equation as
a function of p and q and t.
But all I am interested is,
at this particular location,
have the particles arrived
yet, what's the density.
So to get that, I
essentially integrate
over the momenta, which is
the quantity that I am not
interested.
OK?
Obvious.
I define-- maybe I need
the average kinetic energy
at that location.
So maybe, in general, I need the
average or some other quantity
that I define at
location q and t.
What I do is I integrate at that
position f of p, and q, and t,
and this function O. Actually,
I also define a normalization.
I divide by n of q and t.
OK?
Now, I implicitly used
something over there
that, again, I
define here, which
is a collision-conserved
quantity,
is some function of momentum--
I could put q also--
such that when evaluated for
p1 plus p2 for any pair of p1's
and p2's that I take is the
same thing as when evaluated
for functions of p1 and
p2 that would correspond
to the outcomes of
the collision from
or giving rights to p1, p2.
OK?
And then there's a
following theorem
that we were going
to use, which is
that for any collision-conserved
quantity, what I have is
that I will define a quantity J,
which is a function of q and t
in principle, which is
obtained by integrating
over all momenta.
Chi-- let's say,
evaluated at p1;
it could be evaluated at q--
times this collision operator--
C of f, f.
And the answer is that for any
collision-conserved quantity,
if you were to evaluate
this, the answer would be 0.
OK?
So let's write that down.
So J of q and t is an integral
over some momentum p1.
Because of the collision
integral, what do I have?
I have the integration
over momentum.
I have the integration over b.
I have the relative
velocity v2 minus v1.
And then I have the
subtraction of interaction
between p1 and p2--
addition of the interactions
between p1 prime, p2 prime.
And this collision
integral has to be
multiplied with chi
evaluated at p1.
OK?
Fine.
So then I will follow
exactly the steps
that we had in the
proof of the H theorem.
I have some function
that only depends
on one of four momenta
that are appearing here.
And I want to symmetrize it.
So I change the
index one to two.
So this becomes 1/2 of
chi of p1 plus chi of p2.
I do this transition between
primed and un-primed.
And when I do that, I pick
this additional factor
of minus chi of p1
prime, chi of p2 prime.
And this becomes
division by 2 times 2.
But then I stated that chi is
a collision-conserved quantity,
so that this term in the
bracket is 0 for each point
that I'm integrating.
And hence, the answer is 0.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In the
[INAUDIBLE] theorem,
in the second
[INAUDIBLE], do you
want to put minus sign of the--?
PROFESSOR: There
was a minus sign
worry that I had somewhere.
AUDIENCE: I think in front
of 1/2, at the right term.
PROFESSOR: In front of
the 1/2, minus f of p1.
You say I have to do this?
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
The next term.
PROFESSOR: Here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, if you put minus
sign in front of the 1/2,
then [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's put a question
mark here, because I
don't want to go over that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
but you switched
the order of the
subtraction [? 1/2. ?]
So it's minus [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But I changed
also the arguments here.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Right?
So there is some issue.
But this eventual
thing is correct.
So we will go back to that.
OK.
So what is the use
of stating that
for every conserved
quantity, you have this?
It will allow us
to get equations
that will determine how
these parameters change
as a function of time?
OK.
So let's see how that goes.
If then I have
that Lf is C, f, f,
and I showed that the integral
of chi against C, f, f is 0,
then I also know
that the integral
of chi against this
L operator on f is 0.
OK?
And let's remind you
that the L operator is
a bunch of first derivatives--
d by dt, d by dq, d by dp.
And so I can use the
following result.
I can write the result as this
derivative acting on both chi
and f.
And then I will get chi
prime f plus f chi prime.
Chi f prime I have, so I have
to subtract fL acting on chi.
OK?
And proceeding a little bit.
One more line maybe.
d cubed p.
I have dt plus--
well, actually, let
me do the rest next time around.